bonsoir bonsoir bienvenue dans cette
vidéo dans laquelle nous allons on la
refait bonsoir et bienvenue dans cette
vidéo dans laquelle nous allons enquêter
sur la beauté des gens à l'aide de cet
instrument à hohrod rigaux ça me
rappelle la gare point you beaucoup de
souvenirs sam bon ok c'est parti ce site
va nous indiquer la beauté des gens
qu'on va lui présenter on commence par
exemple avec une photo de moi il va nous
dire notre âge et si on est bon ou pas
bon désolé nous en nous n'avons pas pu
détecter le visage parfait deuxième
essai à j'ai vu un meilleur photo on a
20 ans il est tombé juste il est tombé
je sais très fort et il décompte et hop
on est mieux que bien
mon antenne un botté s'activent à ça
veut dire que je suis vraiment bon et je
voulais vraiment montrer ses accessoires
on l'a c'est une des digues de détective
conan s'il me dit que je suis anclades
su mais c'est c'est chaud quand même à
tort du coup avec mama nouvelles maps et
ce qui va me trouver bon alors il
détecte pas ma nouvelle moche mais moi
il me trouvera stunning as assez
impressionnant quoi effectivement le
site ne s'est pas trompé mon antenne dit
toujours la vérité 25 ans raconte [ __ ]
ça c'est les cernes destour notre cher
président au l'antenne de beauté ce
range
c'est mauvais signe 58 ans il a pris
tout est ok afcc leicester ce site à sa
vache aussi bien que l'antenne de mes
lunettes [ __ ] je suis impressionné non
mais il est bolland d'arrêter les peaux
attendez on apprend une photo il est
vraiment beau regarder on pouvait pas
trouver mieux que ça 64 ans est toujours
ok roland je suis désolé un moment il
faut accepter la vérité là si tu as
besoin de parler ou quoi tu peux
m'appeler tu tomberas sur mon répondeur
est 6e avec une autre photo de moi sur
laquelle je suis vraiment sur mon 31 30
ans et standing
or en ut15 sauvetage de me laisser
pousser la moustache c'est sûr j'étais à
braser oui je suis pas raser avant parce
que je me sentais que c'était pas mal à
moustache et la [ __ ] pour en avoir une
comme ça ça va être compliqué quand même
trente ans par contre ça c'est bon je me
fasse un petit basque et d'un temps elle
est bonne rida cela on connaît bien mika
l'on dit nous la vérité sur michael
whisky et sexy 22 ans plus tard ce
sondage est ce assez fort et nice à
l'antenne à botter s'élever ça veut dire
qu'en réalité les très beaux lucide se
tromper on se fie à l'antenne
automatique plutôt qu'aux sites elle
marche très très bien attention à toi
d'anelka toujours des chouans bordel
comme les meilleurs 34 ans tonyg antoine
tu es beau [ __ ]
douillet boas mais c'est pourquoi
regarder le carré il n'a pas pris en
compte ses cheveux c'est tout bas oui
c'est comme moi si ça pour nos choix en
compte d'un coup ou pas ça kanye west
qui ne sourit jamais tu fais toujours
l'homme fort c'est quelqu'un de bien en
plus parce que j'ai pris sa plus belle
photo 31 ans il a quel âge qu'aider
equest 38 ans à lui donne 31 ans mais
par contre ça lui dit bah écoute qui dit
tu sais sur quoi sera ta prochaine sur
souffle sur la beauté intérieure qui est
dit comme ta femme tu l'épousé pour sa
beauté intérieure un petit con
d'ailleurs en parlant de ta femme tu as
ta ta ta ta ta carte à puce kardashian
22 ans kim kardashian et godlike mais ça
c'est le foot quand ils arrivent pas
passer au travers par exemple lui voit
pas la beauté intérieure de ta femme
kenny voilà la vraie beauté presque sans
maquillage 22 ans nice voilà tu passes
de god la canaille sans maquillage qui
m'a est encore allé maquiller c'est du
bullshit qui est le plus beau entre
sarko et hollande 52 ans oat à sarko
c'est sexe attends moi il me donne 30
ans puisque j'ai un peu de rythme et lui
actu terry qui l'a le site aurait dû
dire qu'ils assurent 70 ans toi je me
suis fait complète pour [ __ ] aof - les
audi nous la vérité sur la beauté de
cyprien 29 ans roth
c'est pas loin de la réalité enfin sur
l'eau sur l'âge parce que sur l'europe
yann en basketteur s'adonne nice 25 ans
du charisme pas me souriait lille avis
sur le b le bébé plus joli que toi yann
je suis désolé testons notre plus beau
profil 29 ans oh [ __ ] il est gentil un
même l'antenne j'étais creuse devinette
s'était pas levé en cul de poule et nous
mais pareil quoi as tu en as abusé mieux
vaut le cul de poule que la grimace
comme une photo de yann et moi qui le
site va choisir et c'est lucas au char à
24 ans tonique mais yann [ __ ] ce site
ne t'aime pas quoi ils préfèrent les
lettres à toi ok on va essayer avec une
photo chouette chouette la chouette sur
la photo cinquante deux ans mais je suis
rom attend avec une blague
il a détecté un poil monga a amassé pire
que y aller sauver koi ça m'apprendra va
être moqué 36 ans nice joueur du grenier
qui agit là joueur du grenier l'a34
[ __ ] le site est presque tombé juste
par contre il sait godlike aujourd'hui
gagner je suis désolé
dites nous la vérité sur jean pierre
pernaut 56 ans
à la vérité éclate en plein jour
jean-pierre atteint j'en peux plus de ce
site
jpp jean pierre pernaut jour peu plus
qu'est le test ultime
dis-nous à quel point et rodman et beau
48 ans nice quoi lui devrait être à même
pas godlike vrai t'as iron man like il
est acté 27 ans ok tu as dans ton gros
cul fabriquer village
j'aurais tellement aimé que carey
semaine sur une fesse [ __ ] j'aurais eu
un fou rire taylor swift taylor swift 25
ans aux gones like voilà taylor la
patronne on l'appelle dans le milieu
elle avait regardé c'est trop le cliché
de la du joli visage quoi mais mais mais
mais j'ai plus d'un atout dans mon sac
je range l'antenne voilà ça c'est une
photo d'elle sans maquillage
hu à 22 en axe non mais ça je lai lurel
et lille mais lunettes s'envole elle
craque elle rage qui toi la souris aussi
[ __ ] le micro tout ça wendy jans qui a
pâti vidéo sur ahold boillon jusque-là
plus des cas n'était pas l'aimer comme
d'habitude je voulais que goode et âme à
la mascotte de l'offre au japon sache
s'il est bon ou pas malheureusement ça
ne détecte pas son visage
il est déçu il est allongé comme ça ils
n'arrêtent pas dépensé depuis thaler il
a rendu triste ou l'essor si vous êtes
pour la mère de celui souhait d'aller
demander à votre mère parce que vu vous
êtes souvent elle vous dira toujours oui
c'est beau parce que je viens de dire
allez au soutien de cette vidéo sur
demande baisse
oh